Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
£500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. but your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
>> Yeah. I have a question to Ali Dawa. Um
I do watch a lot of your videos and I
think you would describe yourself as
someone who's influential because people
do follow you and I just want to ask
like in your videos when you do like
uh speak about I I understand speaking
about the content of some women who are
saying things that are unislamic or not
in line and it's important to spread uh
knowledge and information about that.
But when we speak about, oh, her hand
movements are not feminine. She's acting
masculine or she's so fake. She's
wearing so much makeup. She's done so
much work. How is that Islamic? How is
speaking as such is in line with Islamic
teachings and I'm not attacking you. You
are my Muslim brother and I care about
your ending. And I appreciate if there's
some space for people to reflect and be
like, you know what, I talk a lot on the
internet and it's only about it's a
statistic thing. at the end of the day I
will say something wrong.
Allah bless you in I really appreciate
the way you've um put that forward you
know and I'm a human being you know and
I do make mistakes I do get passionate
sometimes and I've had my differences
with a lot of brothers in the da scene a
lot of male YouTubers Adam Salah Fuzzy
Tube um Nas Daily you know all these
people so to me you know a lot of people
think that oh you're you know you're a
misogynist you're this that like these
are just words to me because I'll be
honest with you I know there's never
ever been a scenario. Nobody no sister
and like they come and accuse me of
misogyny. If they find one statement of
mine, just one statement of mine that
I've ever ever said something that is
hateful towards women. Never. And if any
if anyone can I will retract and I'll
apologize. I'll repent. However, now my
issue is not pertaining to that let's
say specific sisters whoever it is. When
I see anybody and my issue is never
personal. I genuinely try not to have
personal issues with people. Do you get
it? No matter. People call me names.
They call me a spy. They call me
undercover Christian. They call me a
kafir. I've been called them. I've been
I've been called so much stuff. I'm
like, "Yeah, okay. Words don't really
phase me." However, when you have
individuals who are misguiding people,
yes. And this, like I said, with Adam
Salah, I had a back and forth with him.
I met with him in Mecca. We sat down. We
hugged. We're brothers and I told him,
"It's nothing personal. You've done
nothing personal to me. Like, you know,
yes, there might be times where he's
insulting me. I don't it's not that deep
for me. I don't go to seek revenge.
However, if it's something that affects
other people, I have a problem. And
who's those other people? They can be
Muslim or non-Muslim. If I see a Muslim
with their words abusing a non-Muslim, I
will stand up for that non-Muslim. And
my religion calls for me to do that.
That's what Allah says in the Quran,
speak up for justice and truth, even if
it's against your kin or your family
members. When I came to Islam, my dad, I
can remember, he stabbed me across my
face and kicked me out the house. 3
months I was homeless. He's my dad. So
but to me it's like the reality is what
if Islam is the truth I will face the
entire globe because the huck is more
important to me to me why because when
I'm looking at an individual what
message are they conveying to our
sisters or our brothers vice versa if an
individual is coming and saying once
you've popped your baby leave
divorce divorce I'm going to say whoa
hold on a second man do you know what
divorce means you are literally breaking
a family there could be a sister who's
had an issue with her husband scrolls on
Tik Tok and comes across her and she
goes yeah have your baby and leave
divorce him this that now vice versa if
I saw a brother saying the same like
okay listen if she's doing this divorce
her best believe I'll be doing it I
don't pick I would say brother fear
Allah who are you to come to a public
platform on social media that can get
thousands of views and say something so
dangerous like that oh just divorce what
are you talking about bro so to me these
sisters And there was another one who
was an individual who was literally
slandering us, backbiting us, calling us
names, you name it. My issue was not
personal still because she was basically
saying that she was accusing the
prophetam of a heinous crime by because
of her lack of knowledge. So in that
scenario, what we do is in Islam is if
an individual, for example, if I'm
walking here and I hear a sister say
something really crazy or a brother, if
I go and say, "Get the camera out. Why
am I doing that? It's something that was
done in private. I can give an org
ignore it and walk away. She has no harm
to anybody. But when somebody puts a
camera and gets hundreds of thousands of
views and is purposely promoting divorce
or a brother or whoever I it's my duty,
I'm not trying to be Superman here. If I
don't see argument say [cough]
[clears throat]
if a brother has done a video, okay, the
job is done. I don't need to talk about
it. So with that aspect sister and the
question that you asked about okay uh
why do you come and you know say certain
uh stuff I believe that sister if she's
so reckless okay and she is making point
about for example oh men for example
there was another sister men watch
pornography and that is fake and due
respect you're against fakeness okay
sister if that's the case why have you
got lip fillers why have you got 3 kilos
of makeup on your face you have to be
consistent with your world view I'm not
saying anything different I'm saying If
you are talking about fakeness and
something that is not real, then I have
to say be consistent. If you're going to
have a go at the brothers or if it's a
brother saying the same thing, I say,
"Hold on a second, brother. What about
this?" Now, sometimes can I get carried
away? Yes. And sometimes do I say things
and and I try very careful not to
backbite. But sometimes I say certain
things and I'm a human being. In that
specific instance video, I don't
remember what I've said. Now, for
example, if sister's doing that, I will
say that that's a bit masculine sister.
Okay? with all those Jews and the same
with the brothers like if a brother was
doing this
I'll say brother that's a bit feminine
you get that's that's me moving a bit
feminine I I I I brother why are you
doing that I will say the same for the
brother but I'm a human being I make
mistakes and if I've anyhow hurt someone
unintentionally I apologize but anyone
who is trying to misguide the youth I
have no apologies to nobody unless I am
told what you said about that sister is
haram then I'll say I apologize and
repent, I'll take you back. Because the
prophet said, going back to your
question,
I promise [clears throat] Jenna for the
one who protects what's between his lips
and what's between his legs. So that's
why I have to be more careful and if
there's anything that you believe, I've
said if you can remind me later on or
whenever, I will apologize. As far as I
know, I haven't said anything haram.
I've made comments on things that are
real, which you know can be observable.
If an individual, like if I see a
brother, you plot his eyebrows and it's
clear, I'll say, "Brother, stop plucking
your eyebrows." Like, yeah. I hope that
makes sense. Everything you own from
your clothes to your car to your wife or
your husband is going to forget you and
move on and be replaced the moment you
die. That's why Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.